رافق وسبق تولي بنيامينه رئاسه الحكومه
استمرار الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه وعمليات
المقاومه
ابرزها اقتحام جنين المدينه والبخيم قبل
ايام دخلته قوات الاحتلال بغطاء المدني في
شاحنه مواد غذائيه الا ان فصائل المخيم
رصدت التوغل واشتبكت مع القوه المهاجمه
قبل توليه المنصب اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال
مخيم جنين وشنت عمليات دهما وتفتيش وبعد
توليه المنصب ساعات اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال
البلده القديمه في نابلس ايام قليله
وتقتحم قوه الاحتلال منطقه المخفيه والجبل
الشمالي في نابلس فجرا وتشتبك مع مقاومين
لتنفذ في الثالث من كانون الثاني يناير
اقتحاما لمخيم بلاطه وتشتبك مع مجموعات
مقاومه وبعد اقل من اسبوعين على تولي
نتنياه منصبه اقتحمت قوته الاحتلال مخيم
بلاطه في نابلس للمره الثانيه كذلك محاوله
مجموعه خاصه من قوات الاحتلال التسلل الى
المنطقه الغربيه من مدينه نابلس الا ان
الفصائل المقاومه رصدت وجودها واشتبكت
معها وتكررت العمليه في المنطقه الشرقيه
من المدينه بعد ايام
كم استهدفت قوات الاحتلال قطاع غزه مع
تولي نتنياهو الحكم في المقابل هجمات عند
نفذها مقاومون فلسطينيون في الضفه الغربيه
على مواقع عسكريه ومستوطنات من بينها حاجز
حواره
ومستوطنتين وكادومي الا ان العمليه
الابرزه منذ وصول نتنياهو كانت فين في
يعقوب الذات الى مقتل وجرح اسرائيليين
نفذها بشكل منفرد شاب لم ينتمي لاين من
الفصائلتها عمليه اطلاق نار اخرى قرب
السلوان
اهديولوجيا نتنياهو ووزراءه في بيان الثقه
امام الكنيست حيث تعهد بالعمل على تطوير
الاستيطان والحفاظ على الطابع اليهودي
للدوله وتعزيز مكانه القدس عاصمه لاسرائيل
وزياده الهجره اليها فوضع بذلك خارطه طريق
لعمل طريقه لكنيست لم يكن بعيدا فاقر بشكل
تمهيدي مشروع نزع الجنسيه عن اسرى القدس
مع تنام خطاب الكراهيه والتحريض ضد
الفلسطينيين
وزير الامن القومي
دعى الى تهجير الفلسطينيين وتوعد بتمرير
قوانين لفرد حكم الاعدام على مقاومين
ومنحي حصانه لجنود الجيش
وخطب وزير الماليه
الفلسطينيين بالقول اسرائيل ليست دولتكم
القوميه يمكنكم العيش هنا اذا قبلتم
باسرائيل دوله يهوديه